à las vegas cassius clay ou moins
métalliques comme vous voulez 39 ans
rencontrent cette nuit-là riols mais ce
champion du monde des poids lourds si
mohamed ali réussi ce serait le retour
le come back comme disent les américains
le plus extraordinaire de l'histoire de
la boxe il redeviendrait pour la
quatrième fois champion du monde bernard
giroux nous commandent des images que
nous venons de recevoir de las vegas at
home
le jeu de mot est facile holmes à la
maison sia suspect l'instant est venu
narguer son adversaire
leyrit hall est de 8 ans plus jeune que
mohamed ali
le combat se déroulera cette nuit à las
vegas en plein air avec la possibilité
d'accueillir 24 mille spectateurs
de quoi assurer une recette de 6
millions de dollars dont deux seraient
attribués à cassius clay clay a suivi un
entraînement intensif pour perdre 14
kilos et se présenter avec son poids de
forme 98 kg et comme il ya trois ans
à wil mais je ne peux pas le noir ali ne
pourra supporter de barcelone
je vais descendre cette danseuse venez
tôt at il déclaré gagnent carouge ou de
toi ron ce sera terminé il sera à terre
après avoir été le plus grand club
n'est-il pas devenu un has been
un retraité des rings dont la seule
raison de combattre serait l'argent sur
le pur plan sportif on ne voit pas
comment ali pourrait l'emporter
et cette nuit le mythe cassius clay
pourrait s'effondrer
voilà le dit